hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
so season 5 has been with us for a while
now and over that time I've attempted to
drop everywhere on the map to see if
there's a perfect strategy for easy wins
and higher chances of legendary loot so
here are the 6 best landing locations
for easy wins and to keep the upper edge
throughout the duration of the game my
personal favorite is number 6 of course
try to at the end of the video trying to
make you stay as long as possible
hmm I'm a click beta this first landing
location comes from Zack GG he usually
drops at tilty towers for high kill
games well this season he's looking to
improve his win ratio and stumbled
across this spot to the right of
Paradise Palms you'll see an abandoned
farmhouse with two chests in sight it's
also highly likely that you'll locate a
launch pad here too as they spawn more
often at the edge of the map but let's
quickly go outside and see the real
reason this is a great spot just off the
end of the map is a ramp and rift I
won't lie I've missed that jump so many
times so I recommend building out if you
intend to use that rift but let's leave
that there for a moment
travel south from that house to discover
a few weapons and supplies laying around
but keep going and you'll find these two
rock formations hiding two chests at
this point you have a choice go back
north for that rift are continue south
to the junkyard which is usually empty
with potentially four more chests to
loot I would have made this the starting
point but it's hugely unpredictable if
you'll find enemies here or not in fact
thinking about this whole run it'll
probably work better in Reverse going
from junkyard to rock formations and
finally to the house before rifting into
the main part of the map let me know if
you try that way around and what you
think about this and all the other
tactics in the video I'd appreciate it
the next landing spot comes from a
professional fortnight player none other
than Dakotas just as the barren sand
becomes green luscious grass you'll see
a bridge or rather two incomplete ridges
in around 60 seconds there are five
chests salute with another close by up
stairs in each of these buildings are a
chest that you'd expect to be there and
close by there's a treasure chest on the
back of this rusty old vehicle but
there's one more which many people
completely miss venturing down into the
mind reveals this chest hidden away as
we can't guarantee the loot it's
important to have other options nearby
such as Griff's our other chests
straight across on the other side of the
bridge is this room which can contain
another chest and if you are still
unhappy with your loadout run ace for
around 10 seconds to find this Shack and
another vehicle with a chest on it this
also gives you great sight lines into
paradise and the truck stop oh and also
note all the materials you can farm
without any opposition but it gets
better that is not the end just south of
the bridge is a small oasis with a very
high chance of providing risks these are
essential in season 5 my personal
preference is to dive-bomb the last
remaining person in Paradise Palms and
claim all their hard earned loot for
myself
alternatively use the riffs to take up
any position you need the emphasis on
this location is how low players expect
to see someone using the riffs here they
are so well placed and not many people
use them
thanks to decoders for highlighting this
area in fact that leads me on to my next
example segue this next one comes from
Miles Dyer who showed me this in a duos
match his theory is quite impressive and
utilizes multiple riffs as a starting
point dropped down on the moai above
dusty divot use this drop time to scout
other players and maybe spot a llama or
two knowledge of other team's rotations
will help you win the final battle but
the landing part here is the most risky
part of this entire plan you need to get
down there first because however
unlikely there could be someone with you
I find blending on top of the statues
head and then quickly falling off is the
best way to get to the loot first but if
you're miles behind an opponent either
skip to the next part of the plan or hit
a nearby rift to duck out unharmed if
you find yourself all alone open up the
three chests but remember to knock down
the moai for tons of stone which is
arguably the best material in season 5
what miles suggests doing here is now
using the rifts nearby if they spawn of
course to jump to the next Easter Island
head north west of tomato town again
use the time in the air to scout other
teams and check if tomato town has been
pillaged giving you yet another option
in this run repeat all the previous
steps including smashing down that stone
head and use the rift nearby to jump
north west over risky reels
you know what I'm gonna say use the hang
time to scout it out before entering but
if you prefer to stay completely out of
trouble drop on the ice cream truck for
to further chests and lo and behold just
north is yet another set of rifts to use
there's also a possible treasure chest
behind the NAM sign finishing your run
here puts you behind everyone so you can
pretty much bank on not being shot in
the back in total this is a two to three
minute run which yields nine chests and
is relatively safe we could even try
this in Reverse but I have a season 1
tactic which is now hugely viable again
in season 5
[Music]
back in season one a great place to drop
was the architects house in the top
right of the map well in season five
it's still a great place to land if you
didn't know already the architects house
is made of the same materials we use in
game therefore it can be edited as if we
built it ourselves landing on top and
quickly editing out the corner of the
roof will get you to your first chest
next drop down but don't jump because
you may lose a little health and fall on
top of the next chest inside the
building is a third chest - once you've
tooled up here check the vending machine
nearby just in case it offers something
great which can be purchased around here
are trees pallets and rock formations to
loot without being harmed if we're lucky
enough there will be an ATK to
commandeer just by the garage garage
garage to allow us to move to our next
location the ice-cream truck from the
previous entry or use the car to go to
the house in the top corner of the map
for another chest drop and then use the
rifts to the north if needed and
remember that chest by the north side
but depending on the storm distance you
could venture into risky reals to
surprise whoever's the last person
standing there or you could play
covertly and travel down to lonely Lodge
which most likely hasn't been looted
either this strategy can be very boring
for aggressive players the last time I
used it I won with a single kill the
last two opponents died in the storm
think I actually shot five bullets in
that entire match only you can decide if
this play style suits you to some people
it's a little too passive to others it's
a great way to play the game you won't
be judged
play how you see fit
[Music]
I'm going to throw in this one it's not
the most fantastic but it can be used if
you're returning late from a toilet
break or you've been engrossed in your
phone for too long and it's ultimately
the oh bugger I forgot to drop drop
just below Viking Valhalla is an old
film set with a dinosaur's footprint
here you'll find three chests one in the
roof another in one of the vehicles and
one is in the swampy areas just below
this one is on the list due to the level
of random drops here there's usually a
med pack on shields but the best thing
about this location is a rift at the
foot of the waterfall you can use this
to reposition instantly use it to shoot
up to the top of Viking Valhalla by
guarding the other rifts up there or you
could use it to go over to greasy Grove
but without a doubt the best way to use
this is to jump over to yet another
Easter Island head this one just above
greasy Grove again there could be three
chests here and all that stone to claim
to this is another great opportunity to
link rifts to travel huge distances
travelling north you will see a single
rift all on its lonesome just above the
football field chaining these three
rifts together will take you from a
questionable point on the map to any
spot you desire all due to your
awareness of rift positioning and a
little look to see if they spawn right
finally my favorite spot in the entire
game this town in the southeast corner
with Mexican inspired architecture so I
call the place El Pueblo I think that
means village in Spanish please correct
me if I'm wrong its unnamed which makes
it invisible to some players but let's
say it now this place gets a little more
attention every single week so the
likelihood of fighting someone is pretty
high
once you secure the town this is a
weapon fest and shield for days
I regularly pick up a scar a shot
eardrum gun here which makes the rest of
the game much easier should the gree
take over you there are more loot
locations to the bottom right corner of
the map for a few more chests and due to
the positioning there would likely be a
launch pad here - back in El Pueblo our
landing spot just not there are five
potential rift locations which are all
pretty easy to spot this is the beauty
of this landing location you'll be able
to reach any of the other locations on
the list using the rifts jump from El
Pueblo to Dakotas spots at the bridge
chaining rifts to locate other players
like this you will encounter more
opposition from the starting point but
due to the loot options and the
strategic advantages of chaining rifts
this spot is by far my favorite spot in
the entire map during season 5 but what
do you think I'd love to know your
opinions so there we have it 6 landing
locations that can give you an easier
time in fortnight Battle Royale
during season 5 do you have any
locations which you recommend let me
know in the comments and I'll shout you
out in the next episode a huge thank you
to zak GG miles daya and Dakota's for
their suggestions I'm Adam from
Playstation grenades spin a bloody
pleasure I'll see you next time
[Music]
el pueblo Eppolito el Poblado